j'ai sorti un livre où j'ai sortir un
livre et j'en suis vraiment vraiment
fier c'est vraiment content c'est un peu
mon master piece est hors jeu soit si je
ferai un jour un truc plus fou que se
livrent j'en suis vraiment très très
très très content c'est donc le titre du
livre c'est la formule du savoir une
philosophie unifiée du savoir fondée sur
le théorème de belize qui est interne
des probabilités et qui parle plus
généralement de cette philosophie qu'on
appelle le belge à nice mme je parle en
fait de même deux variantes en gros du
bail à nice mme d'un côté il ya le bail
cynisme que dans le livre j'appelle le
bannissement pur qui est en fait le bail
à nice mme solomon au fisc aussi on
pourrait appeler comme ça puisque c'est
celui que l'on n'obtient lorsqu'on prend
au sérieux les équations et les purs m2
selon mme nov que sous le 9 mai selon
mme knox génie informaticiens des années
60-70 a su démontrer avec plein de très
très bonnes propriétés proposées qui est
démontrée et puis dans une autre partant
en troisième partie de ce livre en fait
je parle de balsa nisme que j'appelle
pragmatique c'est à dire voilà nous ont
tant que tel mais aussi présenter jean
certifie ciel qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
sachant que le bail à nice mme solomon
office t'es vraiment un idéal qui nous
est inaccessible à cause de nos limites
cognitives des limites de puissance de
calcul que soit limites cognitives du
cerveau humain mais aussi celle de nos
machines que ordinateur puisque
l'ordinateur sont parfois un peu lent
pour faire des calculs en tout cas sont
pas capables de faire les calculs du
parisianisme solomon au fisc donc la
formule du savoir c'est mon bouquin
publié chez adp sciences vous pouvez le
trouver sur le site de la fnac ou sur
amazon et probablement j'espère dans les
fnac plus les grandes que les petites
mais j'espère que vous pourrez le
trouver
c'est mon book à et ça explique vraiment
qu'est ce que savoir est la raison pour
laquelle ce livre est un livre que je
pense extrêmement important c'est parce
qu'il remet en cause énormément de
choses que on croyait
voir établis notamment par exemple la
méthode scientifique oui parce que la
méthode scientifique passera un peu un
mauvais quart d'heure un quart de ce
livre ou en fait on démontre
mathématiquement que à la ddt de
certaines propriétés qui sont très très
mauvaise
par exemple le fait qu'elle finira par
rejeter toute théorie du vrai avec
probabilité est presque sûrement pour le
double langage dans le jargon des
probabilités mais plus généralement en
fait ce problème de la méthode
scientifique c'est qu'elle est
incohérente avec les lois de la
probabilité est vraiment dans ce livre
les wade profiter c'est un truc c'est le
truc sacré ces trucs qu'il faut croire
en fait pour être prêt s'il ya en fait
deux fondements au savoir d'après ce
livre notamment par rapport à organiser
misme de solomonoff puisque les deux
fondements sont la théorie la
probabilité d'un côté et l'algorithmique
et notamment la thèse de church turing
l'autre côté et pour vous donner envie
de lire ce livre je vais vous lire un
petit extrait de ce livre qui s'appelle
les objectifs du livre donc ça va nous
donner une idée non seulement des
objectifs du litre mais aussi de son
contenu même si je compte bien partager
et justifie l enthousiasme pour le
paysagisme dont j'ai été victime
même si j'ai l'espoir inavoué que ceci
amènera les mathématicien philosophe et
scientifique a questionné ce qu'ils
croyaient savoir de leur discipline
le but de ce livre n'est pas de vous
convertir ce que j'aimerais c'est
surtout partager avec vous quelques un
des joyaux qui m'ont conduit à me
tourner vers le boys and his mme et je
suis prêt à parier un réflexe
typiquement parisien que vous allez être
vous aussi surpris et je l'espère
quelque peu séduits par les conséquences
stupéfiante de la formule 2 bis ainsi
que par son omniprésence dans les
mathématiques appliquées dans nos
propres façon de réfléchir et dans
l'organisation même de nos sociétés
le boys and his m'expliquer pourquoi la
communauté scientifique est bien plus
fiable que chacun de ses membres
et pourquoi nos crétins de cerveaux sont
constamment victimes de l'effet
d'ancrage il explique pourquoi il est
souhaitable de combiner des modèles
incompatibles et pourquoi le rasoir
d'occam est un outil indispensable
il pourra même être la clé pour
comprendre le fonctionnement de notre
mémoire et l'utilité de nos rêves à
l'instar du biologiste et ode aux yeux
ce dow jones qui selon qui rien en
biologie n'a de sens excepté la lumière
de l'évolution
j'irais même jusqu'à prétendre que
nombreux sont les mécanismes qui ne
peuvent être compris qu'à travers les
lentilles bayésienne
la découverte du bail à nice m'a aussi
été pour moi l'occasion de mesurer enfin
toute l'étendue de mon ignorance en
particulier le langage des probabilités
permet de quantifier l'incertitude mais
surtout mon incapacité à appliquer la
formule de pays y compris dans des cas
simpliste comme les ligues de
l'étudiante rôle m'a forcé à reconnaître
que je suis un bien piètre penseurs j'ai
souvent eu une confiance et rationnelle
et injustifiée en mon intuition parfois
accompagnées d'une étrange méfiance ans
la formule de bêtises mais à force de
m'incliner devant la pure bayésienne mon
périple bayésiens mort a contraint à
prendre conscience de menaçable excès de
confiance et à davantage placée mais
crédence sur la formule deux pays
ce sera d'ailleurs là l'un des grands
objectifs de ce livre on cherchera à
lutter contre nos excès de confiance et
à prendre la mesure de l'étendue de
notre ignorance le reste du livre peut
être grossièrement décomposé en quatre
parties dans un premier temps des
chapitres 2 à 7
on va s'attaquer frontalement à la
formule deux pays'' et hop urbanisme
ensuite les chapitres 8 à 13 auront pour
but de révéler la présence cachée de
principe pas et vient dans des
phénomènes dont on ne suspecterait pas
l'aspect bayésiens puis les chapitres 14
à 19 étudieront le paysagisme
pragmatique et ses outils
incontournables
enfin les trois derniers chapitres
seront quelque peu à part
le chapitre 20 intitulé tout est fiction
étudiera les conséquences philosophiques
du béziers nice mme notamment en terme
de réalisme
le chapitre 21 retracera les origines de
mes croyances et questionnera notre
excès de confiance récurrent
enfin le chapitre 22 étudiera les
conséquences du paysagisme sur la
philosophie
malheureusement on se livre comme tout
livre fille n'est absolument pas
exhaustif
je m'excuse d'avancé pour ses
indénombrables déficience en particulier
je ne prendrai pas le temps de comparer
en détail le bail à nice mme aux
philosophies concurrentes
l'objectif est plus modeste j'aimerais
vous aider à comprendre les aspects
importants du bail à nice mme ou du
moins ce que j'en ai compris
en effet comme le livre mon cerveau est
finie lui aussi je vous prie donc
d'excusés toute l'étendue de mon
ignorance je chercherai à relever et à
croiser un maximum de réflexion qui me
semble pertinente
mais je mettrais cependant
nécessairement ce que j'ignore et ce
dont j'ai mal mesuré l'importance
qui plus est ce livre dépeint l'état de
mes connaissances au moment de sa
publication
or jose aspirait continue à progresser
dans mon périple vers la maîtrise du
belize à nice mme pour m'accompagner
dans ce périple
je vous invite à me suivre sur twitter
et a regardé ma chaîne youtube sound for
all ou à partir de fin 2010 huit points
leur alerte je commencerai une série de
vidéos sur la formule deux pays
je vous invite aussi à suivre mes
réflexions et celle du philosophe
thibault giraud alias monsieur fille sur
le podcast axiome que nous tenons
ensemble si l'on n'y a pour but de
discuter de tout ce qui a trait aux
mathématiques à la philosophie et aux
différentes sciences force est de
constater que notre fascination commune
pour les probabilités et la logique nous
a maintes fois amené à parler d'aspect
dubase à nice mme que je n'ai pas pu
aborder dans ce livre comme
l'interprétation bayésienne du paradoxe
de bertrand a mais limitation cognitive
s'ajoute le fait que ce livre se destine
à un grand public et n'exige donc aucune
connaissance préalable
par conséquent je ne ferai pas toujours
preuve de la rigueur dont la pure
bayésienne ne peut se passer même si je
ferai de mon mieux pour ne pas vous
amener à des contresens
ce livre reste un travail de
vulgarisation
néanmoins il ya de bonnes chances que
vous ne compreniez pas tout parce que je
ne voulais pas faire l'impasse sur les
arguments les plus convaincants
je me suis permis de laisser traîner
quelques sections de très haut niveau
ces sections sont étoilés je préfère
vous prévenir
même les docteur en mathématiques parmi
vous risque de sérieusement lutter pour
saisir toutes les notions que je vous
présenterai ne vous précipitez pas dans
la lecture
prenez le temps de la réflexion mais
n'abandonnez pas non plus la difficulté
de ce livre n'est pas croissante
vous devriez pouvoir trouver du plaisir
dans un chapitre sans avoir lu les
précédents
même s'il est sans doute préférable de
lire les chapitres dans l'ordre ceci
n'est pas un livre de cours
il n'y aura pas d'examens je ne vous
demande pas de tout comprendre
je vous conseille même vivement de
sauter les passages trop compliqué et de
poursuivre la lecture
quitte à revenir sur les difficultés
sauter plus tard
mon objectif n'est pas de faire de vous
des experts du business
ce que j'aimerais c'est avant tout que
vous cherchez la beauté et trouviez du
plaisir dans le raisonnement bayésiens
ainsi que dans les sciences utiles à la
compréhension des fondements et des
conséquences du bail à nice mme
j'aimerais que vous mettiez dans la peau
d'un explorateur qui part à la conquête
de terres inconnues et ils découvrent
diverses faune flore culture et paysages
intrigant et qui ne prend pas
nécessairement le temps d'apprendre
toutes les subtilités de la langue des
indigènes j'aimerais que vous profitiez
de votre voyage
si vous suivez mes pas j'espère vous
submerge et enthousiasme de fascination
et de questionnements tel est l'objectif
premier de ce livre